josh duggar has been locked up on
suspicion of possession of child
pornography
but he wanted to be released until his
trial starts
yeah the 19 kids and counting dad was
back in court today
arguing for his freedom
amen multiple witnesses testified at
duggar's hearing where a judge was
deciding if he should be released on
bail
josh has been behind bars since his
arrest last week in new security video
you can see him in handcuffs patted down
and being booked into jail
the embattled reality star pled not
guilty to child pornography charges
his attorneys claimed in federal court
he should be eligible for bail saying
the 33 year old is not a flight risk due
to his
widely recognizable face and should be
allowed to go home to care for
his wife who is pregnant and his six
children prosecutors argue
he should not be around minors i am
extremely
grateful for my parents and my family
josh's lawyers say duggar has known
about the investigation since november
of 2019
and has cooperated he faces up to 20
years behind bars
a trial is set for july
you